this video is sponsored by brilliant org
be one of the first 200 people to sign
up with the link in the description and
save 20% on your subscription today
here's a question for you the world is
in the midst of world war two and you're
a mechanic preparing planes for the
brave pilots who engage in air-to-air
combat for the Allied forces you noticed
that most of the planes planes flown by
your friends and comrades come back to
base with bullet holes in the wing fewer
in the cockpit fewer still in the tail
and almost none in the engine to
minimize the odds that your pilot's are
lost in battle where should you focus on
reinforcing the plane before we look at
the odds of taking on fatal gunfire
let's go through a few other interesting
and unlikely ways to die we'll start
with the least likely death on the list
getting hit by an asteroid isn't
typically something we worry about on a
daily basis but it is technically a
possibility based on the long-term
average risk of all near-earth object
collisions your odds of being struck and
killed by an asteroid on any given day
are 1 in 74 million eight hundred
seventeen thousand four hundred and
fourteen just by looking at that number
compared to the current population of
the planet you might think that
ninety-one people died from asteroid
impacts every year but thankfully that's
not the case it's simply an actuarial
figure based on the fact that a single
asteroid impact would likely kill more
than one person okay 75 million to one
doesn't sound so bad let's move to
something a little more likely your odds
of dying in a freak firework accident
are one in 50 million seven hundred
twenty-nine thousand one hundred forty
one every year on the 4th of July
thousands of Americans go out and make
stupid decisions with store-bought
explosives in 2016 there were a reported
eleven thousand fireworks related
injuries and four deaths so before you
go out and buy a two hundred dollar
backyard bunker buster consider whether
you want to end up as part of that
embarrassing statistic next involves a
personal fear of mine bees and wasps the
odds of dying from a wasp or bee sting
are one in twenty five million three
hundred sixty-four thousand five hundred
and seventy one the reactions to wasp
and bee stings can vary widely one
person could be stung a dozen
and simply take a benadryl to feel
better whereas another person could be
stung once and go into cardiac arrest
every year on average nearly 100 deaths
are caused by bee and wasp stings in the
US alone
luckily for most people experts claim
that the average adult can safely
withstand over 1,000 bee stings as awful
as that would be to experience about
twice as likely as dying from a bee
sting is another common fear dying in a
plane crash at roughly 1 in 11 million
the odds are still very much in your
favor but that doesn't stop most people
from getting a little fidgety in
turbulent weather on average plane
crashes around the world kill about 1300
people per year with young men being the
most likely to survive and an additional
12% of survivors dying from shock later
that's a comforting thought even if you
do survive a plane crash you still have
to escape a second statistic only
slightly more likely than dying in a
plane crash is being struck and killed
by lightning at 10 million to 1 odds
this could be a reassuring thought for
nervous Flyers because most people use
struck by lightning as the gold standard
of unlikeliness even with that
reputation lightning strikes do claim a
handful of lives each year in 2016 39
people were killed by lightning strikes
in the US alone and 14 so far in 2017 if
you're a male you should be about four
times as concerned as your female
counterparts as statistically men are
killed by lightning about four times as
often as women twice as likely as dying
from being struck by lightning is being
scalded to death by hot water at five
million to one odds hot water is so high
on this list because it doesn't look
inherently dangerous especially to young
children every year hundreds of people
died from serious scalding with an
average of 150 deaths per year in Japan
alone at four million four hundred
thousand to one odds this next risk is
probably not one that's ever crossed
your mind every single year over 2,500
left-handed people around the world are
killed from using equipment meant for
right-handed people as strange as that
sounds it makes a lot of sense most
power tools have safety precautions
built-in to one side often the side most
accessible to right-handed people as
most people are right-handed if you
really want to know
most common culprit is the right-handed
power saw jumping forward a bit into the
realm of more likely scenarios your odds
of dying in a train crash are about
500,000 to 1 this could be reassuring to
frequent fliers and somewhat off-putting
to train commuters as most people don't
think about dying on the train as much
as they do aboard an airplane but it's a
stark difference in 2016 there were only
19 fatal air travel incidents claiming a
total of 325 lives versus 2025 train
crashes which admittedly did result in
slightly fewer fatalities at 265 people
if we're going to talk about vehicle
related accidents we can't leave out
your everyday traffic collision driving
in a car something most of us do every
day without thought is by far the most
likely way to get yourself killed out of
all modern forms of Transportation with
odds of 8,000 to 1 the current world
average stands at one point three
million road deaths per year or almost
3,300 deaths every single day
with statistics like that suddenly
getting struck by lightning or dying in
a plane crash seem a whole lot less
likely as for the question from the
beginning of the video if most planes
come back undamaged in the engine it is
not a signal that engine hits are an
unlikely way to bring down a plane quite
the opposite it shows that almost none
of the planes that take fire on the
engine can make it back to base this is
a classic application of conditional
probability and a phenomenon called
survivorship bias when we only look at
success stories we are mistaking the
rare for the typical and as a result
make incorrect estimates for the
likelihood of rare events I came across
this question when exploring today's
sponsor brilliant org brilliant takes an
interesting scenario like our airplane
question deconstruct sit into various
parts explains the relevant concepts and
allows you to apply what you know to
reach a fascinating conclusion it's an
amazing concept because even if you're
not great at math or physics brilliant
teaches you how to think like a
physicist or a mathematician and they
help you along the way by progressing
you from easy to more challenging
scenarios if you like me from 12 hours
ago want to know more about scenarios
like this check out brilliant doors
intro to probability discover this and
lots
more by going to brilliant org slash
second thought which will let them know
you're eager to learn more everyone who
clicks on this link can sign up for free
and explore the first chapter for those
who want to deeper dive into these
engaging courses the first 200 people
that subscribe will get a 20% discount
so make sure to check out brilliant org
at the link below if you enjoyed this
video make sure to subscribe to keep up
to date with the latest content and
click the little bell next to my channel
name to be notified every time I release
a new video you can click here to watch
my other videos or for something
completely different you can click here
to visit my new gaming channel thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video
you